hey everyone it's Mike from waterfalls
here and welcome back to my channel I'm
glad you could join me for today's video
where I'll be talking about the Delta
flip
um you know one of our subscribers wrote
in the comments uh make a video on the
Delta flip but before I jump into what
the Delta flip is and how to look for it
in the order flow
um you know if you've been enjoying
these videos be sure to subscribe to the
channel and click the notification Bell
so you don't miss any new uploads and if
you find today's video helpful hit the
like button for me and be sure to leave
some comments um below you know again
like today's video is is based on a user
comment so your support you know in that
sense really goes a long way in helping
me create more videos just like this one
so if you're getting value from this
Channel and want to see more be sure to
hit the Subscribe button and let's uh
grow together let's grow this channel
out try to make it the the biggest one
on well it's I think it's one of the
biggest on order flow but let's go ahead
and get started on today's topic alright
so the Delta flip now this is a setup
that I uh first released several years
go I actually used to have an indicator
for this on ninjatrader 7. I never
actually ported it over to ninjatrader8
because it's just a very visual
um setup and basically what you're
looking for okay now let me just preface
this
not all setups that I talk about in
order flow appear in every Market the
Delta flip doesn't necessarily appear a
lot in say the e-minis now in some of
the other markets like crude oil it
appears more often okay now why is that
I can't give you a clear definite answer
it deals I think a lot with the makeup
of the actual traders that are trading
that market
um you know in crude oil you don't get
as much retail participation as you do
in the equities I mean just on a margin
basis even on a discounted broker basis
I think you know e-minis you can open up
account and you can trade
with the 500 margin whereas with crude I
think you know if you shop around I
think you know you could find it for
about two thousand so you know you don't
have as as much of that speculative
money
in the crude oil that you have in the
stock indices okay and you know when you
have a lot of retail traders in a market
um you know obviously the participation
is higher and you have more volume
whereas uh commodity markets you know
crude oil is commodity
um you know the majority of the traders
that are trading that market are doing
so for a specific reason right either
you know they could be an oil company or
they could be a gas company in and they
need to hedge their book they need to
buy oil for delivery things like that so
their their needs are
I think in my opinion more expressed in
the actual order flow that you see going
through so what is Delta right we've
talked about this in the past Delta is a
net difference between aggressive buyers
and aggressive sellers in a bar right so
every bar is going to have a Delta now
the Delta flip takes it a little step
further it looks at the max Delta and
the Min Delta the max Delta is
how strong the positive Delta was in a
bar okay Min Delta is how strong
negative Delta was in a bar however
there's going to be times where
either the max Delta or the Min Delta is
around zero right where the aggressive
buyers were never in control right that
would reflect in the max Delta the max
Delta would be literally zero they were
never in control or maybe they were you
know for one or two contracts and that
was it and then you see a volume in the
max Delta of one or two
or same thing in the Min Delta the
aggressive sellers right if they were
never in control Min Delta would show
zero if
they were just in control for like a
split second you'd probably have a Min
Delta of minus one minus two minus three
now the order flow is Trader software we
highlight those Delta numbers those Min
deltas and Max Deltas that are at zero
or one two and three or zero and minus
one minus two minus three four Min Delta
right Min Delta is always going to be
um negative it can be zero but it's
never going to be positive just as Max
Delta will never be negative Max Delta
could be zero or positive right because
Max Delta reflects the aggressive buying
and Min Delta reflects the aggressive
selling and so what you're going to look
for on a Delta flip specifically
is you're going to look for you know
first a red candle right and then once
you got your red candle then you're
gonna focus in on the Deltas right the
max in Min Delta as well as the final
Delta for the first bar in this case
it's the red candle what you want to see
is a small or zero
Max Delta right this is for a bullish
signal okay
so you're going to have a small or zero
Max Delta then the next bar is going to
come in it's going to be a green candle
and it's going to have a small or zero
Min Delta minus 3 which to me is small
and what you're going to want to see
also is the final Delta closing
somewhere near the max Delta okay 107
obviously the seven contracts off 114.
this is a Delta flip so you had very
strong aggressive selling
because it was all aggressive selling in
the sense of you know the Max and Min
that doesn't mean there was no
aggressive buying it just means that
there was no aggressive buying taking
place to cause the max Delta to go
positive okay because obviously there's
volumes trading on the offer right you
need to see 6 22 32 so there is
aggressive buying it's just that the max
Delta was Zero aggressive buyers were
never in control
and it's nice if also the final Delta of
the first bar is close to either the max
admin
of that bar okay so here you got a case
where the Red Bar down it's minus 210
Delta it's right near our minus 215
Delta zero Max Delta followed by your
green candle
with small Min Delta minus three and Max
Delta 107 which is closing right near is
Max Delta number of 114.
okay and you see the move up because
what you had is you had this green
candle right here with strong aggressive
selling
and it's followed back with strong
aggressive buying
and you see the market went up now again
you gotta always try and take it in
context of the market okay
Market have been going up we pull back a
little bit and keep going up you get up
here
okay you can see there's a couple
potentially bare signals here okay you
can see there's a
mint Max Min Delta of minus three
but a positive sorry then the next bar
it's got a Max Delta of zero right but
like what I said you want this first bar
you want it to be closing somewhere near
its Max Delta because this bar it's got
a Delta of four the max Delta is 59 even
though it's got a Min Delta of minus
three technically the Delta is still
positive but fours is very weak and
we're not
closing you know near our Max Delta
number just minus four okay now the next
bar right this red bar is what you like
to see right you see the max Delta of
zero Min Delta of minus 87 final Delta
of minus 81. it says that this first bar
isn't you know technically what you're
looking for right you want to see
in this case since it's a bearish signal
you're going to want to see a nice
positive Delta somewhere near our Max
Delta number you know if it was 50 or 47
or something yeah I would like it but
four no that's that's not good enough
um then you're getting over here okay
now here's another example
you've got
Min Delta of zero
final Delta 50 Max Delta of 79. okay
then the next bar minus 69. Min Delta's
minus 69 Max Delta is zero okay this is
what I would like for a sell-off or up
here near the high
next bar doesn't even go any lower than
this red candle here where you're
looking at the flip to take place so
this flip obviously didn't work right
Market went back up it made started
making new highs so again you have to
take into account right what's coming in
after the flip I talk about this a lot
it's not just that oh okay I have a flip
here
I gotta get short
well you still need the market to move
in that direction just like over here
okay it didn't happen on the next bar
but it happened on the second bar after
the flip took place that's your goal
signal right here
's your flip and you don't even go lower
than this bar this red candle that's not
a good sign right it's probably not
going to work if you can't even take out
the low if you're looking to get short
and you're trading up
that's a trade that's going to fail on
you nine times out of ten
the market should start going in that
direction there was some decent selling
early right because the bar had a minus
52 Delta so there was some selling
taking place here at the bottom of this
candle
but instead of that that selling that
was taking place was being absorbed in
the market went higher but again
this these two bars it's setting up for
the flip but then you need the trigger
to come in and the market to start
trading a little bit lower if it's not
trading lower it's no go
okay let's see if there's anything else
here here's one little one down here
okay
it's a little flip taking place here if
you can see
zero Max Delta followed by zero Min
Delta minus 122 Min Delta minus 80 okay
you know
it's not minus eight like we saw earlier
in that bar so it's a decent Delta
um
then 164 and 167 next bar starts to go
higher right it starts to go up a little
bit it's not a massive move but it
starts to come off a little bit here so
we're coming back down into this area in
here
um
people will say what about this is this
a flip here okay
it's a red candle with positive Delta
even though the max
is positive the Min is minus one
this is not really what it's supposed to
look like if it's going to be a bar
if you're going to be looking to uh get
short
all right because this is the negative
Delta here you'd want a green candle
here right and it's not uh it's not
coming in
then here sort of the sort of
flipping again
you can see three and then zero you know
next bar starts to go up it's just sort
of going sideways that puts us right
where we are right now but like I said
um in markets like e-minis you don't see
it that often this is a one minute chart
just because I think volume is
distributed much better in a market
that's got a lot of retail participation
in it
I don't really see anything taking place
here maybe on an eight range chart might
look a little bit different what is this
that's a one minute let me just clip it
over to an eight range
as you know it's
depending on the type of chart you're
using
um you know
it's going to format the the data
differently but I don't really see any
coming in here either
again you know people be like what about
this right even though there's a space
this bar here would need to be a red
candle
say this bar in this bar right say there
was no bar here in the middle this would
need to be a red candle for that to be a
flip
in the purest sense
um
yeah let's just I'm just scrolling back
so like I said in the e-minis you know
not so much this is British pound I'm
just curious now when you're on markets
that trade thinner volume you got to be
careful okay because like for example
this is a British pound one minute chart
and you're gonna be seeing potential
flips happening left and right you know
on Marcus that trade thin volume right
here you know potentially one here
potentially one here
but the volume is 32 contracts you know
um you know 95 contracts it you want to
be trading a market that has put some
decent volume rather than you know sort
of light volume if anything
um you know maybe trade uh
you know a chart that's going to give
you it's going to format the data in a
way that you're going to get some decent
volumes you know one way you know here's
a
eight range chart and it's you know it's
giving you decent volume straight around
a thousand contracts 800 as opposed to
just you know 37 64 or something
I don't see anything here in the British
pound uh really today now if you want to
get a little bit more fancy you could
sort of
take it over three bars and disregard
the bar in the middle as just sort of
Market facilitating trade if you will
um
you know for example right here one bar
two bars three bars and with the one bar
in the middle
taking place
but there's different ways to trade it
you know the way the first way I showed
you is sort of the the pure way to trade
it that I used to look at it I don't see
anything else there on the eight range
in the British pound let's just go back
I think I had a Euro or so yeah
this is the e-mini's eight range chart
nothing
going on in here you know and again you
know don't be like oh this is uh
a flip here right because it's minus
nine all right maybe you think that
minus nine is good enough for you but
the mid Delta is only minus nine and the
final Delta is at minus nine you'd want
a solid negative Delta on that bar on
that high
like it's let's see what this was run
through a bunch of other markets this is
buns I believe here
let's see if there's anything happening
in the Buns because buns is a nice
contractor Trade It trades decent volume
you know kind of here almost but yeah
just not enough volume in there I like
to see decent volume go through
this is what I was talking about where
you can
almost have one bar in the middle like
here minus 47 minus 71 but that's a
green candle
uh
and I should have this thing
reprogrammed put it back in the lineup
you know here's your one bar in between
here right with your negative Delta your
zero Max here's your zero min
this bar it's not a green candle second
bar you're going to go in the direction
of the color of the candle so if it's
the doji bar that would not qualify
and
see if there's anything else really you
know
this one no because it's a red candle
right you're gonna
if you're going to have the positive
Delta on the second candle it should be
a green up candle not a red down candle
so you're going to say here and here but
it's red red
okay that's not what you're looking for
again I'm just sort of scrolling through
here see if there's any more instances
of the Delta flip
you know kind of this again ignoring
this middle candle zero Min zero Max
with the one candle in between right
then you got your green up candle your
red down candle
you know people say well what about you
know what about this well this Bar's
only got two price levels I like to have
at least some price movement in a bar
rather than just two price levels I like
to see you know the bar cover
three four five price levels rather than
just two
okay well that's that let me just really
quick
I'm curious gold today
uh
you know
like again here's where the bar ignore
the bar in the middle
One Max minus two Min closing near it's
Min sorry closing near its Max Delta
here here this is close enough minus 104
versus minus 78 you know right off the
low of the day to get a nice little
rally
this would sort of set up to be a
potential short
but again we don't even go lower than
this bar
yeah
this is interesting this is not what I
like it's a green candle with a negative
Delta versus the red candle with a nice
positive Delta I just need these candle
colors flip I also like to put price
action some sort of price movement into
what I'm into the analysis rather than
just strictly off the Delta itself I
mean you could but I just find it's it's
more prudent
to also use some sort of price action in
your analysis price movement if you will
so anyway guys I'll end that one this
video there hopefully you get sort of
the understanding of the Delta flip
again it's we used to have an indicator
for this back in ninjatrader 7.
um we don't have it on ninjatrader eight
it's something you can see
but honestly when it's just a pure going
off that pure Delta by itself
you really need to add in other analysis
to it right I'm a big believer in
letting the market take you in so you
got to be watching that the market is
moving in your direction
because you know when you're just
analyzing Delta you're just analyzing
the difference between aggressive buyers
and aggressive sellers you're not
analyzing price movement at all so
that's why I say you got to add in some
sort of
price action some price movement into
the analysis to make the Delta flip more
effective all right so thanks for
joining me on this video I hope I didn't
confuse you guys even more
so if you found this video useful be
sure to hit that like button and
subscribe to the channel if you haven't
already so you don't miss any of my
upcoming videos contents and again be
sure to leave a comment down below let
me know what you think of this video or
you know if you got any suggestions for
another video let me know thanks
everyone bye-bye